a particle of mass two kilograms
so we start with our setup okay
mass is two no big deal it moves in a
straight line
it's s means through the origin so there
you go that s equation they're giving us
is displacement
right displacement
and it's um it's a cubic nothing too
unusual about it
we would usually call displacement x but
it's no big deal s is almost as common
right let's start to much through this
part a find velocity
and acceleration as functions of time
that's what they really mean by at any
time t
okay so all we have to do to go from
displacement
to velocity and acceleration well this
is just this is actually just two unit
at the moment
this is straight line all we have to do
is differentiate
right you could actually just read it
off for me what's the derivative first
60 squared
minus 30 t plus
36 no big deal differentiate one more
time you get 12 t
minus 30 sorry that's really awesome
minus no problem so far find the
resultant force
at any time t okay so don't get too
thrown off by it it's just the language
that we need to get used to
resultant force force
is mass times acceleration that's all it
is right that's all i mean by resultant
force even though it sounds very fancy
okay so you've got your acceleration
equation here and you know what mass is
so the resultant force is just double
the acceleration
no big deal there's the resultant force
now it starts to interweave a little bit
find the magnitude of the resultant
force the magnitude of this so in other
words that's
the absolute value of f magnitude size
the complex numbers okay
find the magnitude of the resultant
force when the velocity is zero
okay so that's not so hard we have a
velocity equation
here it is right here let's solve it
okay when
v equals zero okay we're going from this
equation we have a common factor of six
so i'm just going to take that out
t squared five t plus six
okay two solutions namely
should we factorize it first if you
can't see the solutions right away
we're gonna go minus two minus three
so therefore your solutions right the
zeros
are two or three okay
now this is kind of interesting because
they say find the magnitude of the
resultant force which kind of implies
there's only one
okay but i have two times when the
velocity is zero
as you're going to see in a second
that's not that big a deal but what i do
with this time
where do i put it i want
the magnitude of the force right so i'm
going to stick it into the force
equation
okay so when t equals
two
uh 24 times 248 minus 60
is minus 12 yes
when t equals 3 24 times 3 that's
72 72 minus
60 is 12. why is this
why are we getting actually the same
magnitude think about it
we're comparing what we're really
comparing is kind of like thinking about
gradient gradient that's what velocity
is
versus concavity gradient versus
concavity right
so when you've got these two points
where your gradient for both of them is
zero then you're going to get this
symmetry it's a cubic function right
so that's why when you take the absolute
value of f when you take the magnitude
you're going to get the same thing
anyway so it's 12 we're missing one
thing though we're missing one thing
newton's good units
which are discovering the new concept
today is important
good last one part d
find the speed which is just shorthand
for
magnitude of the velocity so it's the
same idea what we're looking for is
absolute value of v when the resultant
force is zero
okay also not that hard right
okay where's our force equation
right there in fact you might even be
able to read off
the value of time that we need right
when f equal to 0 times equal to times
equal to
solving this equals 0. 24t
equals 60 you divide pretty sure it's
two and a half
two and a half i know hold on two and a
half
yeah two and a half okay that's the time
but what am i actually trying to find
i'm trying to find the speed right
i'll just wait until you're ready
i know not everyone's looking at this
question that's fine but many people are
looking at this question
okay velocity equation there it is
you can pop all your numbers in t equals
two and a half
that should work out to 1.5
and just like before your units are
important meters per second
okay so this is not complicated this is
okay
we're just trying to master this kind of
language resultant force etc
but it's not it's not a big leap versus
what we've been doing in extension one
version okay